[Musique]
j'attendais le nintendo direct puis
c'est finalement un smash direct qui
nous a été proposé
du coup c'est un peu une aubaine pour
moi parce que j'avais prévu cette vidéo
depuis décembre du coup bas j'étais un
livre donc let's go parlons ensemble du
futur de mario avec notamment bas son
prochain jeu quoi bien bon je prends pas
de risque je me mouille pas trop
première idée le portage ou le remake
monde depuis toujours maintenant
commencer à être habitué au 21ème siècle
mais ce n'est pas seulement mario que
nintendo mais on sait que la firme aime
quand même bien ressortir ses jeux en
version un petit peu hd retravailler
histoire de faire des ventes faciles
nous en avons même encore l'exemple avec
les trois sorties quand même de zebda
twilight princess avec gamecube wii et
wii ou et d'ailleurs je pense qu'ils ne
devraient même pas tarder à arriver sur
twitter mais bref ça ce n'est pas la
question bon ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'on est habitué avec nintendo et
surtout on est habitué à avoir une
grosse sortie comme mario disent ils
puis un ou deux petits portage par la
suite ou spin off c'est le cas ici entre
mario bros yachts de luxe ou encore
mario sonic aux jeux olympiques
le problème étant que mario mais coeur
de est présent et ce dernier va
totalement redéfinir l'avenir du
plombier sur la console
car oui techniquement mario maker est
censé apporter tout ce côté 2d tout ce
qu apporte et mario dans ses premiers
opus et même nous donner la possibilité
de le créer nous mêmes donc pourquoi
diable maintenant sortir de nouveaux
jeux mario 2d
je vous le demande alors que mario mais
coeur le fait déjà avec une énorme
touche de créativité et surtout bas
derrière le grand mario d'ici alors
effectivement ils ont sorti new super
mario liu de luxe alors qu'il était
techniquement déjà sur mahomet coeur
mais il s'agit d'un simple portage pour
se faire un max d'oseille
en tout cas ce que je veux dire c'est
que mario 3d world a ses chances
d'apparaître très prochainement mais son
problème reste mario mais coeur où son
style fait partie des nouveautés et a
même grandement servi d'argument de
vente
également il faut savoir que mario 3d
world était déjà présent sur wiiu une
console qui proposait déjà de la hd en
1080p
donc les excuses du portage et master ne
marcherait pas ici pour l'introduire sur
switch et c'est réellement un
pour la communication de nintendo mais
bon il se peut que je sois un petit peu
mauvaise langue
car effectivement new super mario bros
yachts de luxe [ __ ] ce que c'est long
à dire n'apporter que deux personnages
dans son roster ainsi que le dlc de new
super luigi ou qu'ils ont directement
intégrés bref il se peut qu'un portage
soit effectué mais non pas pour tout de
suite
nous en avons déjà eu un cette année il
faut que ce soit dans une année creuse
de sortie néanmoins il se peut que mario
sunshine lui fasse son apparition
outre le fait que le portage nécessite
quant à lui une véritable
remasterisation hd
les fans seraient dans une excitation la
plus totale bon je ne vais pas me
référer aux vieux messages cachés du
style regardez on dit sunshine mais il
faut juste réfléchir logiquement nous
connaissions la passion de nintendo pour
l'heure mario 64
il en pleut des références dans mario
d'ici mario sunshine est dans la lignée
de son prédécesseur
ce dernier serait une solution facile
mais notamment efficace afin de faire
plaisir aux fans que ce soit en tant que
simple remasterisation ou un véritable
remake
cette idée n'est pas vraiment si
farfelue qu'on pourrait le penser
effectivement il existe des lignes et
dans les jeux mario comme mario 64 avec
sunshine mario bros wii et mario bros
wii ou mario galaxy 1 et 2 par exemple
mario au dc a apporté du lourd du très
lourd même
et c'est tout à fait légitime qu'une
suite nous soient apportées comme breath
of the wild est actuellement en train de
le faire après tout les deux jeux
étaient là pour apporter de l'innovation
et faire évoluer leur saga respectives
et ce fut un grand succès là où je
parlais de sunshine tout à l'heure nous
pourrions retrouver cette même idée le
même concept étant donné l'énorme
inspiration de mario 64
l'idée d'une fusion d'une suite de mario
au dc ainsi que mario sunshine peut être
à prévoir mais surtout ce qui me
conforte dans l'idée qu'une suite à
mario ou d'ici puissent arriver et déjà
la liaison que le jeu possède avec
breath of the wild dans sa sortie mais
également que nous n'avons pas eu de
nintendo direct mais un smash bros
direct à la suite du pokémon direct qui
a eu lieu alors j'aime beaucoup smash
bros
mais pourquoi nous présente et indirects
entier seulement sur la présentation du
personnage de bill est
cela veut clairement dire pour moins que
nintendo a quand même de grandes choses
sur le coude de prévu et ils veulent
nous tease est quoi le truc c'est que
c'est hyper facile de faire du bon
contenu sur la suite de mario audi si ce
dernier était avant tout une grosse
innovation mais surtout un premier pas
un test pour la saga sur switch
maintenant que le jeu a bien marché et a
bien instauré son empreinte sur la
console nintendo peut envoyer pour la
suite en réutilisant le même moteur
graphique
par exemple le jeu se termine sur la
libération de peach et de tiara qui se
cachaient dans la couronne de la
princesse je vous le mets en mille lits
dès que la princesse soit jouable et
lance sa couronne et clairement pas à
négliger tout comme le retour de luigi
ou de todd dans le gameplay est ce que
todd du coup lancerait son chapeau
d'ailleurs le concept de régions à
visiter avec l'audi ci est un super
concept à reprendre
ben oui ce dernier permet à mario de
voyage est littéralement partout sans
avoir à justifier pourquoi un excellent
moyen ici de créer de nouvelles régions
visiter de nouvelles planètes comme il
était prévu avec la lune dans le premier
opus
enfin concernant le schapi morphose
nintendo a juste besoin de laisser cours
à sa créativité et créent de nouveaux
éléments de gameplay ou de nouveaux
ennemis pour exploiter ce phénomène est
resté tout à fait innovant mario dc n'a
pas encore pu vraiment bien imprimer son
empreinte
histoire de marquer un petit peu la saga
comme ses prédécesseurs à l'époque qui
était présent avec plusieurs opus
notamment
c'est l'occasion ici le fer avec
notamment un bowser junior en
antagonistes pourquoi pas qu'ils
aimeraient venger son père car pitch
nous arrivons finalement la question la
plus controversée sur le futur de la
saga mario on ne va pas se mentir mario
galaxy 1 et 2 font partie des meilleurs
jeux de la switch on ne va pas se mentir
mario galaxy 1 et 2 font partie des
meilleurs jeux de la wii est pour
beaucoup ce sont même des jeux qui ont
marqué complètement l'histoire de la
console en même temps l'innovation dans
le gameplay et et ouvre un level design
aux petits oignons une identité
graphique forte je pense que la plupart
ont joué à ces jeux ou du moins le
premier nintendo connaît la force de ces
jeux leur succès néanmoins est ce qu'il
est possible qu'un retour soit prévue et
bien mario galaxy souffre du même
problème que skyward sword
ce sont des jeux qui ont été conçus pour
la wii comme mario audi s'il est pour la
switch avec ces éléments de gameplay
mais est ce vraiment une souffrance en
soi car c'est là où cela devient
intéressant
les deuils conne possède les mêmes
caractéristiques que la wiimote et sont
même d'ailleurs plus performant qu'un
wii motion plus encore heureux
la possibilité d'avoir ces jeux est donc
totale concernant le gameplay il serait
tout à fait possible de pointer l'écran
avec un jeu iphone ou de le secouer pour
faire tournoyer mario la souffrance par
rapport à la conception sur wii pourrait
se traduire aussi par le fait qu' il
faut ré implémenté en fait ces
mécanismes sur la switch le fait de
pointer dans mario galaxy était
tournoyer enfin après je suis pas un pro
quoi mais je pense que nintendo ne s'en
n'est tout simplement pas chargée en
fait mais voilà je ne suis pas créateur
de jeux ou même développeur donc je n'en
sais rien mais si nintendo avait voulu
faire un mario galaxy hd et l'introduire
sur la console virtuelle par exemple il
aurait très bien pu le faire déjà donc
c'est que nintendo ne l'avait pas prévu
pour le moment d'après moi dans cette
prochaine sortie surtout que ce soit
mario galaxy ou skyward sword sais je
profiterai d'une belle remise en hd
étant donné que la wii ne pouvait
afficher que du 720p
dans tous les cas je ne penserai pas
pour un mario galaxy 3 pourquoi car tout
simplement cela sous-entendrait une
suite à mario galaxy 1 et 2 sorti il ya
des années sur wii et en termes de
marketing
ce n'est pas vendeur en fait un mario se
suffit à lui-même
on ne joue pas un mario pour son
scénario sortir un mario galaxy 3 après
deux générations de console serait se
tirer une balle dans le pied pour
nintendo afin d'attirer les nouveaux
joueurs qui se diraient bah ouais mais
je n'ai pas joué aux deux premiers je
vais rien comprendre
bah ouais mais j'ai manqué quelque chose
je ne suis plus au moyen de me rattraper
vu que c'était sur wii l'option de
sortir une version de luxe réunissant
les deux je serai donc plus apte avec
par la suite des années plus tard après
que mario ou dc ce soit bien installée
pourquoi pas une troisième version
le temps que les jeunes joueurs
profitent des premiers mario galaxy sur
la switch néanmoins dernière chose a
souligné le fait de devoir pointer
l'écran avec la manette est une vieille
mécanique de nintendo et qui saoule
on ne va pas se mentir c'est chiant
d'avoir toujours la main pointé comme ça
vers l'écran et comme on l'a remarqué
dans ses derniers jeux nintendo essaye
d'effacer ceci est d'innover
si vraiment il souhaite évoluer et
proposer de la nouveauté les codes d'un
mario galaxy 3 serait très certainement
chamboulé bien j'espère que la vidéo
vous aura plu donc si c'est le cas vous
savez quoi faire n'hésitez pas à lâcher
un gros pouce bleu un petit commentaire
et à vous abonner à la chaîne et vous
pouvez également me suivre sur twitter
ou instagram
si mr la caméra coupe elle n'a plus de
place bon bref je disais que les jeux
mario ont toujours été une empreinte est
une manière d'innover pour nintendo et
bah du coup j'ai vraiment hâte de voir
ce qu'ils nous proposeront à l'avenir en
attendant écoutez bas que le lionheart
soit avec vous c'était argot rock
allez bye
[Musique]